now let's take you to some other news
and Burundi is president Pierre
encouraged ISA has died at the age of 55
a government statement says he died of a
heart attack on Monday he was due to
step down from office in August after
the recently held presidential elections
gerousia had been in power since 2005
well our correspondent Malcolm Webb now
joins us on the phone from Nairobi from
where he's been monitoring all those
developments Malcolm we've been talking
about how young and Carosi there was at
the age of 55 what more have when
learned about his death the government
said that he went into hospital on
Saturday and they say that the cardiac
arrest occurred on Monday and then and
that's when he passed away and they just
made the announcement just within the
last couple of hours by tweeting a
scanned statement there's a lot of
sketches and already among Burundians on
social media and elsewhere about the
stated cause of death it one currently
his wife about 10 days ago the knees and
concede to the First Lady of Burundi
flew here to Nairobi seeking medical
treatment for a reason that officially
was undisclosed but a lot of the local
press here in Kenya reported that she
was suffering from Co vid 19 and so now
there's going to be of course a lot of
speculation and getting from Burundi and
from the Diaspora about this claim that
the president has a heart attack and
it's worth noting
the brew indeed pretty much the only
country in Africa that hasn't had any
policies to try and limit the spread of
Kovach 19 and the message from the
government has been largely one of
denial just a few weeks ago president
and grand either himself was out on the
campaign trail supporting the campaign
for his chosen successor presidential
candidate for the ruling party and at
those rallies there were thousands of
thousands of people and almost no
measures taken to try and stop the
threat the spread of the virus the
senior executives of the World Health
Organization were evicted from the
country for criticizing there has been a
position from the government very much
of denial and also a lack
testing and lack of knowledge exactly
how far the virus is spreading there
Malcolm and Kersey's has always been a
very controversial man and he was set to
remain very powerful even after stepping
down in August what kind of a legacy
does he leave now the legacy is one
that's right he was widely criticized
but certainly and from from outside the
runde one of the thing that one of
Bruneian activists and opposition would
say that certainly in the last five
years of his rule then the freedom of
speech the political space has been
clothed he served two terms in office
from 25 2005 at the 2015 announcement to
run then for a third term that caused a
lot of unhappiness people took to the
street because opposition and actually
said that was against the Constitution
he denied that so those protests were
met with a brutal violent crackdown and
ever since there's been a continual
suppression of any voices that are
critical particularly by a youth wing as
a ruling party called the in Venera
curry all those much more widely
described as a militia has been widely
accused across the country of political
killing executions intimidation
extorting money and that's why a lot of
rights groups trade at the political
space in Burundi is now almost
completely non-existent he's under those
conditions that that election took place
last month and the concurrent leaders
chosen successor was announced the
winner even though what remaining
opposition there is and rights groups
and the weren't any international
observers but those commenting from
abroad said that this election wasn't
free and fair Malcolm Webb there our
correspondent following all those
developments for us from Nairobi thank
you very much